[Musik]
formieren der mann war mit
philipp uhr betrieb hat ihr problem zum
nachfolger finden
wieso was danke jahr zuvor
betreiber ist problem schon da war
nachfolger will über tage in einer woche
schaffen
das ist ein netter mensch geprüft werden
die 23 und henry weber tag durch
schaffen oder geht es am sonntag mit
wenigen funktionierenden klarmachen und
nachfolger von betrieben mit mir
in dieser geschichte geht es um menschen
von denen es offenbar immer weniger gibt
um menschen die unter anderem bereit
sind auch am siebten tage nicht zur ruhe
[Musik]
richtig stellen ich hab's nicht vom brot
allein dadurch schon panik
und das ist gegen porsche hat im lotto
würde sie alles was ich sage dass hier
ein bescheidener mensch sind
anspruchslos
ach ja schon ein wenig auf sprich großen
und ganzen das bringt was wir schon
haben sie wünsche im labor bis wo sie
gern genannt wurde der reich ja das ist
eine aktion der lage verschaffen
nach der wirtschaftskrise abrufbar
ist das schon mit 47 und es wird
besonders nutzers wochen inzwischen
bergen tal überhaupt von gondo gab es
früher 12 bauen betriebe jetzt nur noch
die stars sie wohnen auf 1250 meter über
meer also ein bisschen näher am himmel
als wir unterländer
[Musik]
hier ist nicht nur die luft dünn sondern
auch der fahrplan des postautos
[Musik]
man sieht ja mal 20 gewählt wurde die
novelle pure warum frische luft zu jagen
der chef das ist doch etwas in
schallstadt nicht berauschend aber die
machen ja aber die taylor schon über
jahre macht das macht ihnen über tage
wochen ja schon mal nicht schaden
ich war mit der kollege und somit
darüber also ich war schon immer brav
der lohn bin ich geboren sie will eine
stadt sieht sogar gewachsen war
mit landwirtschaft sehr schwierig
jaja aber nicht einmal gut aus einem
orca petrus der abfall zusammen
aber das sind meiner frau einer lehre
zum beispiel
wenn das licht der welt
[Musik]
die politiker vorschriften so wenig
überrascht dass ich da schon konstant
fahren wie ich sein möchte daraus ein
geschäft machen
yannick hat im keller ausgebaut um
künftig käse zu produzieren die nach
anderen wegen vertragen werden wir noch
unser land rief von verdi wird oder sie
zu war lecker und so funktioniert es wer
hofer wird es wohl nie fertig das eher
rückläufig und die idee dass das das
zusätzlich stand weiter geht also in
großem kontrast
die akkus präsentiert und
verkaufspreisen der cern barrieren
spüren und langsam
louis jacobs quali ist junggeselle
widerwillen er hätte gerne geheiratet
leider habe ihm keine gewollt sie sich
einsam fühlte abonnieren
hier einmal auch weil hier die studie
konnte regel mehr sekunden zurück
er ist selbstständig also doch die
gebote zur ruhe
[Musik]
also wenn man denn niemand welches wort
oder das geht soll das letzte match des
partners group hat sich also situationen
zur situation der show nummer zwei war
stolze 20 gemacht und die haben zu tun
und da hätte ich die partie
wahrscheinlich vor sohn auf der piste
wieder zu gewalt und der gläubiger
gestellt würden
[Musik]
im jahr 2000 zerstörte eine halbkugel
13 menschen kamen damals ums leben
darunter zwei seiner brüder
[Musik]
nur wer glaubt wird ewig leben das heißt
wenn man der motorisch und divx geld in
china haben dem herrscher nicht nur im
kopf mit ritonavir darum die worte aus
harburg die hier fliegt dann fertig die
ich gibt's nicht frau im paradies ja das
war das war bisher waren sich alle per
flugzeug
sie und das ist ein schöner tag
schlechter ist
jetzt ist es endlich somit zu weniger
produkte glaube nimmt so ja es geht
sicher mit will
das was mir ich habe darüber warum
ja so ist das wiederum scelsi
umliegenden häuser singen woche
[Musik]
[Applaus]
bei den anstoß dreijährige charme kommt
jedes zweite wochenende zu besuch
als er geboren wurde war am 17 die
mutter 15
sie sind relativ jung vater wollte ich
das so blanik sie ändert sich nichts
wenn wir jetzt gesehen er ist sehr froh
weil dann immer wieder ganze popkomm als
nicht sagen
also wie viel von der metro war in
katholischen ländern hat man verständnis
für die schwächen der menschen denn auch
in momenten der schwäche entstehen
bisweilen kleine geschenke gottes
der große war gross hatte ja auch
verstehen nur familie und ich werde
jetzt ist ein schmackhaft machen nicht
gar nicht machen das machen
oft machen will
das anders machen gar nix julian
schieber
[Musik]
es gibt immer weniger bauernbetriebe
aber die die überleben wachsen ins
paradies konnten in den vergangenen
jahren laufend neues land das nicht mehr
bewirtschaftet wurde dazu pachten
so sind 50 hektaren zusammengekommen
davon kann ein bauer eine familie
ernähren wenn er denn eine hand
ja der spur
es ist freut dass sie selber nie
hinkämen zumal er sieben kinder
78 häuser ja ja ist schon mehr ist weder
schön
sie brachten war das nicht zwar wird das
musst du nicht da bist du ja noch nie so
voll und überall möglich
nur
[Musik]
janni clubs in la paz auf einer
nachbargemeinde von blick aber das
stadtleben sei nichts für ihn gewesen
seit er denken könne gab es ihn zum
onkel gezogen
in die natur und in die idylle kurz und
zwischen bergen
in der stadtbücherei down under
[Musik]
hier kenne und helfe man sich noch dass
die verwandten vorbeikommen wenn an den
stetigen hängen geholt wird ist zum
beispiel selbstverständlich nicht so
also weiter schweifen wenn das gute doch
so nah ist
wann sind sie alle zwei monate ferien
zurück und er ist sehr schmal und wo
sind sie
dann geht's nicht und inszeniert sich
wurde
eine finanzielle frage juni gratis
bald folgte prompt mit allem drum und
reicht von der summe ca
weil wir ja schon vor zwölf rote meer
maschinen und danach an ich hoffe wir
machen ja nichts auf dem friedhof
der tod ist
[Musik]
was machen sie heilen kann man sie
pensioniert werden
dahinter schaffen nämlich jetzt
besonders ungesund
das hat meine mannschaft
das war so ein betrieb übernimmt
niedliches handy gibt das den import
rohstoffen trierer etwas immer noch nie
besser weiß
jean ist diskussion der junge das ist
gar 100 wochen rollt aber das sind ja
vorgemacht und außen hin dass nichts
braucht all den java sein vorgänger jung
maxi und und china von universe gekürt
also bei uns das regional ist hinter dem
konto werden ab und zu aber da müssen
wir drüber schießt man nicht alleine ist
und das ist daher im moment gehört der
betrieb den beiden quadratisch zu je 50
prozent wenn der onkel 65 wird also in
fünf jahren wieder treffen
alles übernehmen bei mir ist der
langsame kanten und somit lange her und
wenn ich sehe dass nur die studie nicht
erklären durch das genick
und wenn ich sehe dass er den ball dann
aber das muss man ja schon mal
[Musik]